[Musik]
hallöchen wenn die süßen heute gibt es
eine richtig hübsche erdbeertorte und
das ganze in oberg im besten fall haben
wir nämlich gutes wetter die
erdbeersaison ist da wir machen einen
schnellen jahre stellt otto die hübsch
aussieht und lecker schmeckt und dafür
starte ich jetzt mit dem boden
ich habe jetzt vorab butterkekse
genommen diesmal die schoko variante
könnte auch ganz normale butterkekse
nehmen und die einmal fein gemixt das
ganze könnt ihr auch in einem
gefrierbeutel machen mit einem nudelholz
hauptsache sie werden schön feiern und
dann gebe ich geschmolzene butter mit
dazu und das ist schon unser noweck
boden und falls ihr euch fragt wo sind
die ganz genauen mengenangaben die sind
immer genau genau also auch generell
andere varianten harrer krebse oder so
diese standard butterkekse ja das geht
auch so ich vermisse das hier und dann
geht's auch schon direkt weiter so ich
habe nichts vorbereitet und zwar einen
junge hübsche tortenplatte ich nehme
jetzt gerne rosa und darauf gebe ich
ganz einfach einen tortenring wir
brauchen hier keinen boden gebrauchen
kann springform direkt darüber geben und
dann kommt unser boden rein und den
rücken wenn richtig schön fest an
[Musik]
zu den keks boden jetzt ganz kurz an die
seite geben und wir machen weiter mit
der creme dafür habe ich hier
schlagsahne ganz kalt aus dem
kühlschrank hier in meiner rührschüssel
die rührschüssel ist ebenfalls kalt und
der schnee wesen auch jetzt ist auch
kalt wenn ihr das alles beachtet dann
kann euch nichts schief gehen jetzt erst
mal eine halbe minute an gibt dann nach
und nach seine fest dazu bis es komplett
steif ist es dauerte ungefähr eine
minute oder anderthalb
[Musik]
so die sahne steif die gebe ich ganz
kurz an die seite und jetzt geht es
weiter in der nächsten schüssel und da
habe ich jetzt mascarpone drin und das
süße ich jetzt mit vanille extrakt und
ich finde vanille in verbindung mit
zitrone ist megageil deswegen mach das
jetzt so dass sich dann auch im citroen
zitronenschalen abprallen gebe achtet
darauf dass ist eine bio zitrone ist den
saft brauchen wir nicht bei dem rebsaft
also nur die schale
anschließend kommt der zucker rein und
dann verlieren wir das nur ganz kurz ihr
dürft man es gab ja nicht zu lange
verrühren weil es um flüssigkeit
verlieren deswegen nur ganz kurz
[Musik]
seine lockere krebs jetzt fertig nicht
echt mega gut also wenn dir jetzt schon
nach dem probiert gerne mal nicht die
vorfreude größer sondern es gebe ich das
bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank weil es ist schon recht warm
hier und in der zwischenzeit werde ich
die erdbeeren schon mal drittel dann
zeige ich euch die hübsche deko bis
gleich
[Musik]
so die erdbeeren wie kommen jetzt mit
der spitze nach oben in den tortenring
der clip wie von alleine macht euch
keine sonne leicht andrücken moment hab
das auf jeden fall so und jetzt gebe ich
die restlichen erdbeeren die ich er in
so sehr kleine stücke geschnitten habe
einfach auf dem boden da habt ihr die
geballte ladung richtig lecker und
generell habe ich jetzt auch also bis
hierhin habe ich glaube ich nur zehn
minuten gebraucht oder ungefähr 10 12
minuten soll das ist jetzt hier alles
schön auf dem wo ich hab jetzt ich muss
aufpassen nicht ich leg hat mein robots
lang 1 watt und dort so super richtig
gut aus schon mal und jetzt habe ich
auch die creme aus dem kühlschrank
genommen und gebt die einmal komplett
drauf und dann schließen wir das ganze
mit danny d mit kokosraspeln ab zu haben
dass idee ich hatte nämlich als ich die
schule gemacht habt kakaopulver genommen
ja ich fand es nicht so nice aus und
kokosraspeln passen besser
[Musik]
und so kommt jetzt die erdbeertorte für
einer stunde in den kühlschrank dann
sitzt alles schön die zuckerkristalle
lösen sich auch alles ist ein bisschen
fester und trotzdem sehr sehr cremig und
anschließend fragt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich wie entferne ich jetzt
diesen tortenring oder dass man alles
weg kreis und die app in verrutschen da
schnappt ihr euch ganz einfach den bug
formloser ich hatte immer tortenring
besser genannt so kam es offenbar vor 20
jahren aber im endeffekt könnt ihr damit
der nicht nur tortenring lösen also
torten von torten ringen sondern von
allen möglichen backform die hat nämlich
eine sehr dünne flexible klinge und dann
macht ihr euch auch nichts kaputt und
ganz am ende gebe ich ganz
minimalistisch nur noch ihr eine
erdbeere um darauf die schön gefächert
habe und das endergebnis ist für mich
perfekt
optisch und auch geschmacklich und euch
jetzt ganz viel freude beim nachmachen
ich habe jetzt gar nicht mehr darum
herum wir genießen das jetzt bei sonne
auf dem balkon und die ganz genaue
mengenangaben findet ihr natürlich in
der video beschreibung hinterlasst
diesen wieder ein bäumchen nach oben und
abonniert natürlich main kanal kostenlos
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal wieder kein fehler gemacht
in der cdu
[Musik]
noch braucht